all right so this is the pod I apologize
for this by the way I've like barely
shower today so I'm just yeah you right
tell yeah but yeah so this is episode I
love this setup this setup is that it's
a fraud no was it some sort of guard
those turned into a frog and he's on the
verge of death and Finn and Jake are
encouraging him to die oh really
and but he has this quest of defending
guarding these three beans to are really
really good and one is totally evil and
he can't let him ever grow but he
doesn't know which is which so if it
agrees to do it the Frog dies very
quickly it grows a beard turns a dozen
blows away and they decided to plant the
beans and they're just gonna kill
whatever the bad one is but they grow
and they can't tell which is the bad one
cuz one is these very cute little pigs
another is he's very cute little wands
another is this pod that lets out ice
cream just constant ice cream and they
think the pigs are okay but then they go
and wreak havoc and turns out ice cream
is their weakness so Finn uses the ice
cream I love them phrase don't kill you
with ice cream and pretty much and yep
but that's about it
and they blow up into butterflies and
flowers and bows yeah and maybe
strawberries I find my sales driver that
was one of my favorite parts though when
the first one blows up and they get like
rained on they're like Oh gross you know
what I'm wondering I'm wondering if cuz
again I said look at that like you know
man the surprise like a sensor didn't
have a bra with that but I think if you
have really Pleasant things come out I'm
like it's okay like if you made it like
heck if you made that they explode ice
cream even then that might be too much
because it's kind of gooey and like
organ blood ish oh but as long as you're
making like very solid happy Pleasant
things and they serve a funny pop you
know there's a sound
thank you sound as a explodes that will
make it alright so um uh you know it's
good I like the setup more than the
actual payoff like I was kind of hoping
like I guess I really like those setups
like one is good one is bad which is
which um and I like they do sort of play
with it but yeah in the end I thought
made the pigs like start talking like
gangsters or something like viola Bailey
you know yeah yeah yeah just gave it
more of a personality but the fact
they're still just I don't know they
still don't talk and they just sort of
point the wives as I thought maybe a
good available funnier but um but it's
fine I mean you know that I think for
the set up house I think it'd be a
little bit more but it's okay what am i
glitter by itself I don't know about
with glitter with rainbows um I was
actually okay with it I liked the whole
idea of even when the pigs are you know
shown to be evil they're still cute some
of that like they have a little bit more
shadow and a little bit more lines but
although there's still just cute but
would it be wouldn't have been funnier
if like May they had cute voices and
when they're do evil things they're
doing the cute voices too like you know
going everyone that then really funny is
just I don't know I felt like there's
like one other there's one other punch
in there like a good like good joke to
be done I just couldn't that I didn't
couldn't quite see in there but oh don't
worry you'll actually get some of that
later on
oh well most of the things in this
kingdom are cute alright know you'll
you'll know you'll understand okay but
yeah I mean it's it's okay like I didn't
think it was bad all right that just
thought I like you know that's a butt
crack shut the you you just want
everyone else ceases there's a scene
where the ice-cream pod opens ah first
of all it starts leaking and it's brown
liquid coming out brown goo and is
this big green thing that has a crack
down and then a little hole in the
middle and just Jake just going back
yeah cuddly-looking it out like am I the
only one seeing this is this like the
hairdo in the last Avatar movie where
the last airbender where it's just like
you can't look it's bigger like I can't
be the only one who sees this so I don't
know it looked like you was sure you
know just licking strikes ass and looks
really creepy to me so yeah made you
laugh I know yet you are we going
you do need to grow up yeah mister seen
butts everywhere it looks like a but I
remain silent
but again I can get away with it because
they say it's it's ice cream and that
makes it oh yeah does anyone else see
the butt okay just leave in the comments
if you see the butt because that I was
disturbed okay I was disturbed seeing
that he'll just program it was there it
was there
so yeah closing thoughts nan what's here
gonna be in more butts in the next one
or at least triple the amount
hmm
I quit